c'est quoi cette ne s'arrête pas avant
d'avoir trouvé quelques actes
eduardo dickens troisième bataille en 5e
régiment
je suis revenue depuis un an et je n'ai
pas travaillé une seule journée
ma fille et ma femme sont deux états
plus loin quand je vous dis que
j'accepte près n'importe quoi madame
c'est près n'importe quoi salaire
minimum et c'est ce soir alors indiqué
le centre louis tchèque vous accueille
magasins à rayons dans toute la gloire
bassin de vie
tous les deux libres et nous la fille ou
alors que l'on se mettre en chasse et
vous tuer vous n'avez pas de signal
cellulaire ou de ligne terrestre
si vous ne l'avez pas remarqué qui se
confond avec ça on leur envoie un
message vous ne nous empêchera pas
d'entrée vous ne la garde n'avait pas
senti on protège entièrement dédié à
nancy de me promettre à me défendre
ces points sont pleins on éliminer le
plus grand nombre possible
m
[Musique]